what does you understand it is their
problem with you competing I'm legally
and medically female but the people who
oppose my existence still want to think
of me as male they use the language of
that I'm a man and so there's this
stereotype that men are always stronger
than women and so if you think of trans
women as men then you think there's an
unfair Advantage sport is a as a human I
wonder why you think that just explain
what that means for for you we care
about the Olympics we care about our
favorite soccer like sorry football club
um we care about the Rugby World Cup we
care about sport it is Central to
society so if you want to say well I
believe you're a woman for all of
society except this massive central part
that is we don't necessarily believe
you're a real woman though do we no the
history here you got it wrong we don't
believe you're a woman in the bathrooms
or in the sport Point what is the well
she said she is legally and medically a
woman what does that mean in this case I
don't know there's the line because did
she get did he get his his Pisha dual
cut off and now and have a fake vajayjay
put in and now that means he's a medical
woman where's the line then on when a
man with still the same man muscles man
lungs man heart man bones man reach man
man you know a chemical recovery in
their in muscles well you're just biased
I think that's where does that where
when where did how did you change that
into a woman I just think you're a bit
biased I am biased to be quite honest
I'm biased by Logic a bit racist and
sexist so I don't know I think that's
what you are yeah and transphobic I
couldn't forget that one yes yes no
because you're afraid of trans people
I'm you're afraid of their existence
idiophobe let's keep this massive
central part that is Sport then that's
not fair so fairness is the inclusion of
trans oh you care about fairness but you
want to come in with a physical
advantage to a woman's League what do
you care about and you're going to
preach to us about fairness I can't with
these people good just let's hear let's
hear what it has to say do you think
you'd have been a world champion cyclist
if you hadn't transitioned I don't think
I am a world champion because I'm a
trans woman
I put in the work and again we have to
remember I lose most of my races I've
lost against the specific CIS women
complaining about me being that's
embarrassing so you were born a man and
you can't even win in the women's
we're bragging about that is 9.58
seconds the women's is 10.49 seconds
there is an undisputable advantage for
for men in sport isn't there we talk
about men being faster than women we
have to be very careful what we're
talking about so the example you gave
was at the most feed and strength Sports
they have a 10 10 12 advantage in most
scientific opinions at the elite level
right so when we look at the very best
athletes in men and women you see this
roughly 10 to 12 Gap but if we're
talking about like the average man we're
talking about the ioc we're talking
about the elite level of course if you
look within a single sex event the
difference between so then back to your
logic if we're talking about the elites
or talking about the regular people then
wasn't your point earlier it's all or
nothing yeah so now you're going off
about navient leads around the average
people so what you're just contradicting
yourself let's see what first and eighth
is very large and the difference between
first and first between Sexes is often
smaller than the difference between
first and eighth within a sex so by that
logic would you not have male or female
categories whatsoever I think that's a
great question I think that's a
different question
so I think it's not fair to trans people
to say well in order to fix whether to
include you in sport let's just
radically shift How We Do sport the ioc
has no appetite for that at the moment
so everything is your way or the highway
and that's all it is your way what you
want you want to be you want to cut off
your schlong dye your hair pink row it
out paint your nails and beat up women
in sport and it has to be your way or
the rest of us are [__] okay I got
it
I'm Claire are you clear for that at the
moment yeah my eardrum is gonna burst
but sex categories they studied by the
the Swedish
instead of the calendar
which I know you've read
closely it does say that there's very
limited change in thigh strength 12
months after transitioning and taking
testosterone suppressants
fly strength if you know more than
anyone else obviously a huge thing
particularly in in sport but
particularly in track cycling
do you accept that there may still be an
advantage
is it possible yes
um however the range of body sizes and
strength levels oh just I'm just gonna
logic I'm just gonna I'm just gonna keep
making excuses and spin and spin and
spin and spin the comments aren't for
this there's no way spin the facts until
they fit what I want because it's all
what I want wait it's not about what's
right it's just about me me me me me and
you got to change everything for me or
damn you all it's possible it's possible
that's crazy
um however the range of body sizes and
strength levels within a sport you can
be successful with massively different
body compositions even within my sport
so again a British example would be
Victoria Pendleton teeny tiny skinny
legs best in the world if Chris Hoy was
to transition
at a master's level if he was to take
take testosterone so he just used an
exception as his rule he just uses an
exception as his role welcome to the
world agenda mum a master's level if he
was to take take testosterone
suppressants for 12 months and then come
here and everyone's buying me up not
everyone's buying my other female some
people are buying certain mixed gender
so we should start teaching that some
people are some people are born with
three eyes with mental illness and we
need to call it what it is and treat it
and not cut off the body parts of young
people
and call it treatment you know without
trying to solve the mental problem and
making a very important Point sorry you
know my favorite point someone made was
is if let's say I was Rand handicapped
Trent handicapped so I wanted to cut off
my arm because I identify as the person
before yeah what about it so that's a
mental illness but wanting to cut off
your dick isn't yeah wanting to get a
hysterectomy and cut off my boobs uh you
know attach a sausage to to my crotch
that's that's medical care that's not
mental illness that the military should
pay for
eign
because now he's a girl
would Chris we don't actually know that
again we are making this massive
assumption
um but I think that's a fair assumption
to make I don't you no we we haven't
seen this in the rest of sport so again
trans women have been allowed to openly
compete since 2004 since the 2004
Olympics all right Sonny so this year
for my birthday we're gonna do something
special what are we doing we are going
to Greenville South Carolina on April
1st my birthday is the second and we're
gonna go on a 24-hour overnight walk
with retired Navy SEAL Tom Shay okay
you're going to be able to stay awake
for 24 hours we'll see what he does on
this walk is he takes a small group of
people and he helps them to understand
the way they think and the way their
mind works so that they can unscrew
their mind and they can build a better
life and everybody that I know I know a
bunch of people personally that have
done it and they say it is absolutely
the most amazing day of their lives and
they walk away completely changed so I
think it's something cool that we can do
together and you don't get to say no
because it's my birthday present awesome
okay so everybody we're inviting you you
to join us on this 24-hour walk with
Navy SEAL Tom Shea in Greenville South
Carolina you have to sign up in advance
it is a secret location that you do not
get until right before the event starts
there's only a maximum of 30 people that
get to come and we're going to be there
we're going to be the two and we'd love
for you to join us if you guys are
interested in coming along with us on
this crazy Journey you can go to
tomshave.com and use Sunny fast200 for a
fat discount all right we'll see you
there April 1st see ya is this bigger
than sport is this about
is it more important that that
trans women feel that they're included
than to maintain a
category within sport
I think you're you're asking me is like
trans women inclusion more important
than fairness in sport but again my
point is that trans inclusion is
fairness it is unfair to exclude legal
and medical women trans women what do
you mean legal and medical women because
you convinced your woe government to
make it okay for you to change your sex
on your driver's license that now you're
legally like under what law under your
state law maybe your name your nation's
life I know what is it like certainly
not under God's law you're not you're
born a man you're a man it's amazing
that you can actually change what it
says on your ID that's horrible that's I
mean that's it's just it's crazy to
think that because
I mean we've had the same discussion you
guys have probably seen it but like God
forbid you in a car accident and they
have to you know do surgery on you it's
important to know what sex you are like
there's a ton of scenarios where it's
important to know it's just you know and
and we'll get beat up for being called
transphobic and it's not that I have a
problem with people being trans I don't
at all at all go ahead do what you want
but don't now come as a man a biological
man whatever despite what she says born
raised male physically male come into a
woman's Sport and put them in danger go
live your life do what you want to do
and stay the goddamn hell out of out of
classrooms because what they're trying
to do is take this very rare very
unusual condition and make it mainstream
and they're trying to build a trans Army
of a bunch of little kids that are going
to grow up and say I'm trans little kids
that don't know the difference between
like that don't even know the days of
the week yet they're confusing them
about their gender so it's terrible what
they're doing terrible so yeah if I am
anti-trans I am anti this anti-trans
movement but I am not anti-trans go live
your life go ahead just the way I'm
going to live my life over here and I'm
not going to force it on you look at
this it's not discrimination it's just
biology understand the difference in
unfairness to the woman competing it is
definitely discrimination that was the
whole point of setting up a separate
category for biological woman that was
like the feminist movement that was like
the OG feminist movement was to get
women their own sports it wasn't like
men discriminating and being like oh you
know we don't want you playing with us
it was like no you're gonna lose every
time we're gonna kick the [__] out of
you in any physical sport there was both
because there were sports like
um like marathons that that women
weren't allowed to compete in yeah but
men are still better but it doesn't
matter they that had nothing to do with
their safety or we're going to beat you
you know you couldn't just say because
you could say that's a bunch of weakling
men too you can't play because we're
just gonna beat you anyway that's dumb
argument so there was discrimination
against women but women were also smart
enough to know that they needed their
own league for you know for competition
for obvious scientific reason reasons so
just because that that was there was
discrimination in that case this don't
go lump in your crazy ass self in with
women with half the Earth's population
and taking making your plight our plight
and our plight your plight because it's
not the same thing much bigger than
sport in that it's
it's the proxy for all of trans not
feeling very compassionate today
um Talk of
whatever this is about to end a bathroom
shifted into sport by people who don't
care about sport so I think it's clear
that this issue is bigger than sport
okay she said something I agree with
just bigger than sport I also don't want
someone with a schlong in the bathroom
with my little girl or me it's not too
much to ask I don't want someone with a
schlong in the bathroom with you either
we have gender neutral bathrooms all
over this country now go in there don't
tell me you have to come in the women's
room with little girls and ladies okay
oh God I'm angry today I'm trying not to
be I'm trying to be nice but I I'm at
the point where I'm really frustrated
and I've had it with with this nonsense
of them lying to everybody and tricking
people into thinking that they're being
discriminated against when really
they're just trying to force a way of
life on an entire nation that doesn't
want it so stop because we're starting
to push back because we've had it all
right thanks for watching everybody
sorry I got so angry today but you know
what are you gonna do
[Music]